Si su vida fuera un libro
y Ud. fuera el autor,
¿cómo querría que fuese la historia?
Esa es la pregunta que cambió mi vida para siempre.
Al crecer en un lugar cálido como el desierto de Las Vegas,
todo lo que quería era ser libre.
Soñaba despierta con viajar por todo el mundo,
vivir en un lugar donde nevase
y me imaginaba todas las historias
que contaría después.
A los 19 años,
el día siguiente a mi graduación,
me mudé a un lugar donde nevaba
y me hice masajista.
Con ese trabajo, solo necesitaba mis manos
y mi mesa de masajes conmigo,
y podía ir a cualquier lugar.
Por primera vez en mi vida,
me sentía libre, independiente
y totalmente en control.
Hasta que mi vida dio un giro.
Un día volví temprano a casa del trabajo
con lo que creía ser una gripe
y menos de 24 horas después
estaba en el hospital
conectada al respirador,
con menos del 2 % de probabilidades de sobrevivir.
No fue hasta días después,
cuando caí en coma,
que los médicos me diagnosticaron
meningitis bacteriana,
una infección de la sangre que se puede prevenir con una vacuna.
Durante los siguientes 2 meses y medio,
perdí el bazo, los riñones,
la audición en el oído izquierdo
y las dos piernas por debajo de la rodilla.
Cuando mis padres me sacaron del hospital en silla de ruedas,
me sentía como si me hubiesen zurcido
igual que a una muñeca de trapo.
Pensaba que lo peor ya había pasado
hasta que semanas después vi mis piernas nuevas
por primera vez.
Las pantorrillas eran unos trozos de metal
con tubos atornillados para los tobillos
y unos pies de goma amarillos
con una línea que sobresalía en la goma, desde el dedo gordo hasta el tobillo,
que parecía una vena.
No sabía lo que me esperaba,
pero desde luego que no me esperaba eso.
Con mi madre a mi lado
y entre lágrimas,
me ajusté aquellas piernas rechonchas
y me puse en pie.
Me dolían y me apretaban tanto
que solo podía pensar
en cómo iba yo a recorrer el mundo
con aquellos trastos.
¿Cómo iba a vivir
una vida llena de aventuras e historias
como siempre había querido?
Y ¿cómo iba a hacer "snowboard" otra vez?
Aquel día volví a casa, me metí en la cama
y así fue mi vida
durante unos cuantos meses.
Estaba como inconsciente, huyendo de la realidad,
con las dos piernas posadas a mi lado.
Estaba totalmente destrozada, física y emocionalmente.
Pero sabía que para salir adelante
tenía que dejar marchar a la antigua Amy
y aprender a aceptar a la nueva.
Y ahí es cuando lo vi claro:
ya no tenía por qué medir 1,67 m.
¡Podía ser tan alta como quisiera!
(Risas) (Aplausos)
O tan bajita como quisiera, según con quién estuviera saliendo.
(Risas)
Y si volviese a hacer "snowboard",
no se me van a enfriar los pies.
(Risas)
Y lo mejor de todo, pensé,
es que puedo calzar la talla de todos los zapatos
de la sección de rebajas (Risas)
y así lo hice.
Así que tenía ventajas la cosa.
Y fue en ese momento cuando me formulé a mí misma
esa pregunta fundamental en la vida:
Si mi vida fuera un libro
y yo fuese el autor,
¿cómo me gustaría que fuese la historia?
Y empecé a soñar despierta
igual que cuando era pequeña.
Y me imaginaba a mí misma
caminando con elegancia,
ayudando a otros en mi viaje
y volviendo a hacer "snowboard".
Y no solo me veía a mí misma
bajando a toda leche por una montaña de polvo,
sino que podía sentirlo de verdad.
Sentía el viento en mi cara
y mi corazón latiendo muy rápido
como si estuviese sucediendo en ese preciso momento.
Y ahí es donde empezó un nuevo capítulo en mi vida.
Cuatro meses después ya estaba subida a la tabla de "snow" otra vez,
aunque las cosas no salieron para nada como yo esperaba:
no podía flexionar las rodillas ni los tobillos
y en un momento dado traumaticé a todos los esquiadores del telesilla
(Risas) cuando me caí y mis piernas
se quedaron pegadas a la tabla
(Risas)
y volaron montaña abajo
mientras yo aún estaba arriba.
(Risas) Estaba horrorizada,
como todos los demás, y muy desanimada,
pero sabía que con los pies adecuados
podría hacerlo otra vez.
Y ahí es cuando aprendí que nuestros límites
y obstáculos solo pueden hacer 2 cosas:
o detenernos en el camino
u obligarnos a ser creativos.
Estuve investigando durante un año y todavía no sabía
qué tipo de piernas usar,
no pude encontrar ayuda.
Así que decidí hacérmelas yo misma.
Mi fabricante de piernas y yo nos pusimos a juntar piezas
e hicimos un par de pies con los que podía hacer "snowboard".
Como pueden ver,
tornillos oxidados, goma, madera y cinta adhesiva de color rosa fosforito.
Y sí, puedo cambiar el esmalte de uñas.
Estas piernas fueron,
junto con el mejor regalo que nadie podía hacerme en mi 21 cumpleaños
—el riñón que me dio mi padre—
las que me permitieron perseguir mis sueños otra vez.
Empecé a hacer "snowboard",
volví a trabajar y a la universidad.
Y en 2005 cofundé una organización sin ánimo de lucro
para jóvenes con discapacidad física
para que puedan practicar deportes extremos.
Desde ahí, tuve la oportunidad de ir a Sudáfrica
donde ayudé a ponerles zapatos a miles de niños
para que pudiesen ir a la escuela.
Y este febrero
gané la medalla de oro en la Copa del Mundo 2 veces consecutivas,
(Aplausos)
lo que me convirtió
en la mejor "snowboarder" adaptada
del mundo.
Hace 11 años, cuando perdí mis piernas,
no tenía ni idea de qué podía esperar.
Pero si me preguntasen hoy
si me gustaría cambiar mi situación,
tendría que decir que no.
Porque mis piernas no me han hecho discapacitada;
en todo caso, me han hecho más capacitada.
Me obligaron a aferrarme a mi imaginación
y a creer en mis posibilidades,
y por eso creo
que podemos usar la imaginación como una herramienta
para derrumbar muros,
porque en nuestra imaginación podemos hacer lo que queramos
y ser lo que queramos.
Creer en esos sueños
y enfrentarnos a nuestros miedos directamente
es lo que nos permite vivir la vida
más allá de nuestros límites.
Y aunque el tema de hoy es la innovación sin límites,
he de decir que en mi vida
la innovación solo ha sido posible
gracias a mis límites.
He aprendido que los límites son el lugar donde termina lo real,
pero también donde empiezan la imaginación
y la historia.
Así que la idea con la que me gustaría desafiarles hoy
es que quizás, en lugar de ver los desafíos y las limitaciones
como algo negativo o malo,
podemos empezar a verlos como bendiciones,
como regalos magníficos a usar
para prender la mecha de nuestra imaginación
y ayudarnos a llegar más lejos de lo que jamás pensamos poder llegar.
No se trata de derrumbar los muros,
sino de alejarlos
y ver los lugares maravillosos
a los que nos pueden llevar.
Gracias. (Aplausos)